I do think we need to go further too one  thing the left does really well is  everything  like running a society or having a  flourishing life or anything like that  but they're really good at politics and  so what the left can do is they deal  with the cultural issues and they also  deal with the political issues and they  win in the movies and they win in the  elections too and so yes I think we need  to take control of our kids education we  need to homeschool we need to send them  to private schools we need to push for  Charter Schools but we also need to go  into these government schools we need to  fire Bad Teachers we need to boot out  and protest these terrible school board  members we need to kick out CRT kick out  radical gender Theory and demand that  our students are taught true okay  [Applause]